a couple of days ago i got a chance to
do the joe rogan experience for the
fifth time
but first time in the new texas studio i
also got a chance to interview him
afterwards for the podcast that i host
and ask him all the usual philosophical
over romanticized
russian questions that i usually do on
the podcast
a bunch of people message me asking so
how's the new studio
so instead of responding to everybody
individually i thought i'd make this
video
to give my thoughts on the new joe rogan
austin texas studio there's a few quick
points i want to make
but overall tl dr
is uh i love it so first let me say from
the perspective of a guest and what the
studio actually looks like in real life
i think it looks great in real life and
i believe it's
an improvement over the previous studio
in several ways so
one the previous studio actually has a
lot of extra space
that feels useless and there's something
about removing that space
that makes the studio feel more intimate
i definitely felt like i was pulled into
the conversation more
like if we take somebody like larry king
from cnn check him out look into it
is he has this like creepy closeness to
the guests
i think this new studio actually
extracts a really nice balance
to me that's interesting as a podcaster
and that's something i talked to joe
with is how do you create an atmosphere
where you just forget that the rest of
the world exists and you lose yourself
in the conversation where you're
really focused in on listening and
thinking about what the other person is
saying
another small thing that i think is
actually really cool from a guest
perspective
is there's only now one big tv versus
two tvs so when you're looking at
something in the previous studio
the uh one chimp was looking at one tv
and the other chimp was looking at the
other tv
and if you know anything about uh chimps
or dogs or humans
there's a powerful signaling thing with
our eyes when we're both looking at the
same thing
there's like a more of a bond to it when
we're looking at the same thing same
object or
like same image in the tv so there it's
just nicer experience to be able to look
at the same thing together
and then look back and also from a
camera perspective you can see
what everyone is looking at whether it's
two people or three people or four
people
so i personally love it now from the
perspective of what the video actually
looks like
that goes into lighting camera positions
also the texture of the background so
when the camera is doing the
autofocusing or adjusting of the lights
it does
a good job all of that now to comment on
that part
i want to say how amazing jaime is for
people who don't know
jamie varner is the i guess producer
of the joe rogan experience but he also
does a million other things
it's just a creative mind of his own uh
a photographer
just the creator of all kinds now me
again as a podcaster i do many of the
things that jamie does but i do it much
worse
so i get to really appreciate the
quality of his work
so much of the setup the wires the
configuration of the audio and the video
and the management of that the switching
of the cameras
the ability to google all that comes
together as a
as a vision and uh implementation by
jamie
and so this new studio from a video and
audio engineering perspective
is very much a creation of jamie and i'm
telling you now
he's done a masterful job and it's
quickly improving
so just like you did with a previous
studio to be constantly quickly
improving
until it got to that level there
everybody got used to he's doing the
same thing here
i guarantee you'll be at a stellar level
very quickly the previous times on the
show i
i knew how good he was but this time i
actually got a chance to chat with him
offline about some of the details
of all the stuff he's doing and it just
took my respect for him to another level
and hopefully i'll convince him he kind
of said yes to get to uh
to come on the podcast so we can talk
about uh
some of the genius behind young jamie
and also i want to say
that to me as a podcaster and an
aspiring young jamie myself
it was uh it was really nice to see
how humble and self-critical
he is you know given all the success of
the show
given everything that's been done given
so few screw-ups so few imperfections
given the level at which he's able to
with one hand
be a solo producer of an entire
video podcast where he's switching to
cameras and with another hand
be able to google at a moment's notice
given all that he's extremely
self-critical extremely humble
that's just inspiring to me because uh
it echoes to the way
i see the world as well so it gives me
hope that
if i continue seeing the world that way
i'll be able to eventually figure out
how to do this podcasting and
engineering thing
uh the right way so for whatever it's
worth
i love it the video will keep improving
and i think just like the
cyber truck which will likely be
manufactured in the same
city of austin texas i think people will
eventually see it not as ugly as they
did at first
but as badass and also as i mentioned to
them on the show
spotify is better than youtube in terms
of music
i hope that next time i take a ride in
that spaceship
i'd love to do a cover of voodoo child
by jimi hendrix
all right check out the conversation
with joe should come out next week
hopefully i didn't say anything
ridiculous but i probably did
love you all i'll see you next time
you